i am particularly worried about it
because my dad he's very old he's always
leaving the tv on the bills are really
hefty now i usually turn off all the
lights trying to save power if it's
unnecessary you turn it off immediately
dealing with the enormity of this could
determine the course and the success of
liz truss's time in office
tomorrow she will return to the dispatch
box to announce how she will halt a
further big rise in energy bills to stop
them reaching 5 000 pounds a year the
prime minister's plan could end up
rivaling the response to the coveted
pandemic in size again paid for by
borrowing
another economic crisis for this man
andrew bailey governor of the bank of
england meeting new chancellor
quasiquating for the first time earlier
he suggested britain is facing the
biggest turmoil in a quarter of a
century in the 25 years
since this
regime came into existence
uh certainly up until the last few
months actually inflation has averaged
pretty much exactly on target
this is the said before this is the by
far the biggest shock we are facing
during the life of that big problems
demand big solutions but from a prime
minister who spent most of the last
month telling us temporary measures and
large handouts were not the answer what
won't work is simply a sticking plaster
of handing more money out without
dealing with the root cause what i don't
support is taking people
taking money off people in tax and then
giving it back to them in handouts that
to me is gordon brown economics
supporters say the shift is necessary
and pragmatic i think this trust in the
leadership election so this is the kind
of conservative i am this is why the
lead and these are my principles but
equally she said i'm an accomplished
politician who knows when those
principles have to combine
with action to deal with the kind of
imperatives the kind of events that i
describe
this trust dismissed the idea of
freezing the energy price cap
when that was a proposal put forward by
the labour party
but after a u-turn in the last couple of
weeks tomorrow it will form the
centerpiece of what might be her most
important announcement in office
now all prime ministers thrive when they
show flexibility when they get into
power
but her mps will be looking closely when
it comes to those promises she made on
the campaign trail and whether she's got
the political firepower and the cash to
deliver them
labour says borrowing isn't the right
way to fund the plan energy companies
are making 170 billion pounds in the
next couple of years we understand and
that's simply wrong and they should play
their contribution and secondly if the
government carries on borrowing all
that's going to happen is that is that
although energy prices for the homeowner
will will remain stable
interest rates will go up and so their
mortgages will go up so people's credit
card bills will go up so we're robbing
peter to pay paul
a prime minister of principle but how
far will she now have to flex when
facing a once in a generation crisis sam
coates sky news westminster